hi my name is Alec and I'm presenting on
you doing
so hi I'm Alec I've been enter a
boyfriend for three years and I'm gonna
be talking about you new ink it starts
at a quick overview we're gonna talk
about first can go into the motivations
of Union link don't discuss what's new
about it this year from last conference
there a jump into some examples of these
simulations widening and rendering some
navigation with the Union add mesh and
building unity projects from the Wolfram
language alright so motivation so what
do you need provide to the Wolfram
language users provides a powerful
physics engine called physics also
provides really nice lighting and
rendering just include stuff like
shadows and reflections and also
provides other built-in utilities such
as pathfinding and terrain generation
and from the Uni side go from white
which provides a nice scripting
environment as well as some algorithmic
content creation such as meshes textures
audio they very easily import from
America and community and lastly
provides tracking analytics for tracking
a scene object data and so on
alright so what's new this year so I've
added a lot of scene functions such as
creating opening finding merging and
saving and closing scenes so control all
that now from the local language also
we've added functions for controlling
the editor mode from the home language
for things like playing pausing stopping
and stepping frame by frame through a
union B simulation we've also added
functions for capturing a screen from a
certain unity camera as well as building
directly from the Wolfram language we
also add support for materials textures
Pargo systems and made our existing
functions more flexible alright so let's
jump in but first we have some physics
simulations we're gonna start with a
wrecking ball scene so we will go ahead
and load the uni link I'm gonna load a
new uni project called three simulations
I'll just take a second
all right there goes I have our new
project here we're gonna go ahead and
create some asset directories as we see
you added all these directories down
here they want to go ahead and create
some textures and materials and put
those in the asset directory so first we
can create the scene and using this
create a new scene function
and we're gonna want to save that scene
by saying scenes wrecking balls that's
completing the scenes folder and
wrapping a file around it will mean that
I'll actually save it to the assets
folder now I can see that after go to
our scenes folder and now contains our
wrecking ball scene then go ahead and
add some textures so here we just create
textures tell it where to put it and our
assets folder and give it an image and
it will directly convert it to a DXT
format and stored and our textures
folder which you can see down here next
we can use those textures to create some
materials by just using cranium material
tell it where we want the material to go
and then giving it the texture and here
we also change the texture scale so that
it fits the plane better so we go down
here we can see the materials now has
these three materials alright next so
now we want to create some geometry for
our scene the first to make a platform
see it here and we add the texture our
caution material to the share material
of that platform and we can set it
directly like this using the part
specification another way we can set a
shared material is nd actual create
function or we want to specify the
option properties and we can say share
material and give it the material we
want so here would create a box and give
it our box material you can see you
there it's a little small
I'm gonna go ahead and add a budget by
to that box so it'll be affected by
physics and then we're going to create a
prefab from that box it's not I can see
if you go to our prefabs folder that
prefab was added to the assets directory
and now you go ahead and delete that
original box we do not need it anymore
alright and now we want to build a wall
out of boxes so go ahead and make a
bunch of positions that are in a row
here and go ahead and see those
positions are it just creates a grid of
cubes so go ahead and create a empty
game object called wall to share as a
parent for a wall then we can go ahead
and create multiple game obvious from
that box prefab at the different
positions with their parent being the
wall so this will add a lot of boxes as
a child
to the wall object here this take a
second and there we go now I have our
wall of boxes next we want to add our
wrecking ball we go ahead just add a
unity sphere called breaking ball and
set its position there you want to add a
hinge joint this is a physics component
that will create a hinge that allows the
ball to swing back and forth I'm gonna
set its anchor to be above the walls
that way it will swing directly into the
wall so you can do that next we're gonna
get the component on the ball that's
rigidbody I said it's mass be 100 inside
of one this will make it a lot more
heavy and make a lot more powerful when
it hits that wall see over here we have
the ball up there and its axis is
centered above the wall I'm actually
gonna make a pulse a little easier see
this is all esthetic so I see it made a
pull from the ball to its hinge Center
and lastly we're gonna set material of
our ball and pull make it look a little
better now I see it's all metallic
material all right now however scene
setup we're gonna go ahead and be able
to run it using this unity play function
so we go back over here a second it'll
run the simulation there we go
so we see it goes through and hits all
the boxes and then it swings back
alright it's fun but we go ahead and add
some more boxes make a little more
interesting
so first let's reposition our camera by
finding it and then setting its position
and angles so that we have a nice side
view of our scene then we're going to
find that wall we're gonna copy it
multiple times to get a nice box shape
then add the lead our original wall and
now you go ahead and play it I have it
so that initialize it's in the pause
state so now it's in the simulation mode
but it's pause so we can go ahead and
use this unity step function the step
100 frames forward I didn't stop again
go ahead do that you'll see it runs and
it stops then we can use our unity
screen capture function to get the image
of the camera you can see it's just now
hitting the boxes I'm gonna go ahead
unpause it and see that it continues
and then we can go ahead and top
stimulation all right that's it for the
wrecking ball I'm actually gonna work
with cloths let's go ahead and save that
scene and let's close unity and reopen
it with the fig stimulation so just take
a second here all right so I'm gonna
create a new scene called cloth we're
gonna go ahead and create some materials
for our cloth seen this would be right
material and a gray material all right
they're going to create three rods or
cylinders that the cloth will fall onto
and see they're centered here and center
the scene go ahead and make their
clatter radius a little bit bigger so it
collides better with the cloth go ahead
and change our camera position to have
it better than you have the scene
can I see our three rods here it's
actually gonna actually add the cloth
the first we'll make a disc mess and
discretize it so it has a lot of
triangles you know a lot of points I
want to make the cloth move
realistically then we're going to go
ahead and create a new mesh asset from
that mesh so we can see at our mesh
folder now I have this nice this mesh
asset there go ahead and reposition that
mesh you're going to create a game
object out of it
and last week I said it's material to be
that red material now if you like over
here I see our cloth there go ahead and
add a cloth component this is a physics
component that will make the versity to
act like a cloth let me go ahead and on
that clock component I said the capsule
kleiers that it will collide with to the
capsule hours of our rods and lastly
from the stayed scene you like over here
we see our the cloth with the three rods
so then we can go ahead and run the
scene hit play a second start here I
should see the cloth fall onto the rods
you go back and forth and there we go
alright and that's the cloth simulation
next up we're going to go into some of
the rendering and lighting I also go
ahead and close that unity project and
open a new one called rendering
he opened here
alright let's create new scene called
render alright now we're gonna start by
making a nice room just a bunch of
planes on each side for a wall we go
ahead and get those positions and
rotations of those planes let's go
through and create a plane with the
proper position and rotation here so if
you do that come back over here see we
Hou have a nice box of planes to contain
our scene next we're gonna actually add
some objects to our scene to make it
more interesting
so first let's reposition our camera so
that's now inside the room there when
you go ahead and create a teapot from
our teapot mesh we're gonna do the same
for the guitar a spiky and a sphere and
a cube now if we go back over here I'll
see you all of our object in the scene
and I see you laid out it's a little
hard to see what they are so we go ahead
and change your integrals on those so
I'm gonna go through create a new
material for planes set this chair
material on all planes to that material
I'm gonna find the for material or for
plane and says material to be a slightly
wider color I see it's changed there and
now we're going to actually add
materials to all the different objects
which now we colored them I notice the
speed sensor has some reflection on it
that's because we are able to set
material properties now so does
glossiness I metallic the fools that way
acts like a mirror go ahead and add a
reflection probe to that sphere so that
way this reflection probe will bake and
reflections of the environment and then
allow us to see other questions on this
year all right and we reset everything
static and doing this will kick off the
unity lighting baking process so to go
here which he had started preparing to
bake on this will take about a minute
and 30 seconds
I wish about the weight I've actually
done it's already in different scene
let's go ahead and open that scene and
appears now I've been saved
it's alright
go ahead oh just make those getting real
quick let's go back to our vendor seen
our planes through the camera create our
objects it's fear create cubes and
create all of our materials after
flushing probe and set the setter
alright so say about man thirty seconds
surrender some go ahead ask some cameras
we're gonna get some more perspectives
on the scene so we can have a camera
that faces the back and camera doubts
from the top down I'm gonna get our
reference to the front camera I can see
we have the different cameras here our
scene the back and top are here so we go
ahead and use our union screen capture
and give it different cameras to get the
view of those cameras this will be the
camera front so be the camera from the
front and we can also set a custom image
resolution this resolution can be higher
than the actual scene we see here in a
uni editor and lastly we can get the
view of multiple cameras at once you can
get all three cameras here and see what
they see let's see
it's taking about 50 more talking to
surrender go ahead and move past this
and come back if we have time afterwards
alright swim ahead and save that scene
then close unity we're gonna open up a
new example called navigation here we're
going to go over the you need add mesh
agents and obstacles you see I can do
pathfinding with the built-in unity
functions we're here it should be
opening a new new project called
navigation all right there we go
well let's create a new scene called
maze go ahead and create a bunch of
materials for our maze all right and see
all the materials added next we're going
to add a platform and so that's material
to be a platform material and make it
static and we see it's added there by
next we're going to move the camera to
get a better view point on our scene
we're going to create a player which is
just a capsule say that's material and
then add a camera to that player I see
have a little bread player there and
alas we're going to add a lot geometry
to the scene let's go ahead and do all
that here real quick so we add all of
our walls ramps a little door in the
middle and some meshes as obstacles you
can see those load in here
there get our blue wall with ramps
leading up to the top of the wall and
our all of our obstacles so now anyone
actually add some navmesh functionality
to it so we can go ahead and create a
nav mesh agent on the player we can add
an obstacle to the door that's a de
carved nav mesh and when it's moving as
well it's nice and one for all of our
orange obstacles that we have here we
just add up school to them and see them
there unless we're just gonna use unity
execute here to call the static build
nav mesh function to build our nav mesh
so right now here now if you go over
here to the scene view we should be able
to see the nav mesh show up soon depend
of speaking
take a second here
right that right nice taking a little
bit too big
Oh chance there the scene all right
there we go listen even say to create
the navmesh
right now I see in light brew we're here
we had the Bab mesh covering our entire
scene showing where the agent can go now
we can actually have some functionality
with it so we can go ahead and create
this function Doug create nice control
and the local my original book here
freaking control our scene so go ahead
and run a simulation and maximize it
once we have our player our objects so
if we run those quick controls it'll
create a dynamic here that will show an
overview of the scene and give us some
controls to move the player and change
the camera position all right so our
players here we can click anywhere on
the scene it will create a new
destination and use the path higher to
go find it and when see the player
actually goes to that location we can
click somewhere else and we can also
close the store in the center so now we
can close that door and see you Chet's
there and then the player has to go
around and find a new path ok
open that and also switch views so I'll
click over here it's in a player here
and then I'll switch to view to have it
be the players first-person perspective
going down and I also stop and start the
agent
make it stop where it is and then
continue I can go ahead and stop the
simulation and then close the dynamic
alright and last we are going to talk
about a building from with the welcome
language and go ahead and close that
project and reopen our critic simulation
project with a wrecking ball just take a
second here
all right it's open again just make sure
we can do the opening scene give it the
wrecking ball now he just called Union
build here and it will build the project
to the actual project directory
I'll just say a second and now we see
the location of our build project go
ahead and open that should get a prompt
about the resolution that we want to run
at taking a second here opening it just
do it manually all right so we can see
this is the application it built in our
project directory and then go ahead and
run that I should see our wrecking ball
yeah this is a standalone application
that doesn't need any unity year welcome
I wish the port on it and this function
has different options you can set the
build targets to be like the platform so
I can be OS X OpenGL and Windows so on I
can also set the build name and build
directory as well as setting a custom
icon for it alright and that covers the
presentation any questions